50.
That's how many apps were available
in Android Market
as Google Play was known
when it first launched
alongside the first
Android device in 2008.
A few days later, Android Market opened
for all app developers to register
and start publishing their apps
without any review
or validation requirements
from Google, OEMs, or carriers.
For us as developers,
the ability to distribute apps
and the possibility of monetizing them
through up front payments,
in app billing, and advertising,
directly to the owners
over a billion android devices,
is one of the most exciting opportunities
made possible by the Android ecosystem.
Growing up in the dark days
before smartphones and the Internet,
If I wanted a new game or app,
I had to go to a physical store
and pay for a cardboard box
filled with floppy disks or CDROMs.
As developers, a big part
of our business plan back then
was how to get those boxes
of our software onto those shelves.
Or in the world of mobile,
how to secure a carrier or OEM deal
to get our apps preloaded
onto devices.
Today I can install
over a million apps or games
created by tens,
if not hundreds of thousands
of developers via Google Play,
all with a click of a button.
That's translated
into tens of billions of app installs,
an incredible opportunity
to distribute apps to Android users
in hundreds of countries.
Now in the early days of Android,
being fast and launching first
was a pretty solid strategy for success,
but as those first 50 apps
quickly grew to hundreds, thousands,
and now over a million apps,
it takes a lot more than speed
to stand out from the crowd.
These days, the tables stakes
are a base line of quality,
and willingness to create
great experiences for all your users.
Of course, app quality can
be somewhat subjective,
but over the years we've identified
the core criteria that users
identify with apps of high quality.
And to make your life easier,
they're all available
on the Android developer site
for you to review.
This is the same checklist
that the merchandising team
for Google Play used to ensure only apps
of quality are featured
in their promotions
and editor's choice categories.
And they include everything,
from following
the app design guidelines
to supporting
different screen orientations,
tablet's, and other devices.
And, of course, ensuring that
your app is stable and performant.
So, with over a million apps
already available in Google Play
it's no longer just a numbers game.
We don't need just more apps or games,
or even more developers.
What we want is high quality apps
from great developers, like you.